Well, good morning again, church.
Uh, my name's John, one of the pastors here.
Uh, it's great to see you.
If I haven't had the pleasure meeting you yet, I'd love to.
So come say hi. Come find me. Uh, we are glad you're here.
Uh, whether you've been here a long time
or just today's your first time, we're glad you're here.
Go ahead and take your copy of God's word.
Turn with me back to First Samuel
as we continue our sermon series
through this great book called He Shall Reign.
The whole book of first Samuels, we're gonna walk
through over the next few months.
Now, as you turn to chapter four of First Samuel,
let me warn you, we're attempting a massive task today,
four chapters in one sermon.
Now, I know some of you're like, wait a second,
I didn't sign up to be here till dinner.
Okay, so obviously I'm not gonna read every word.
We're not gonna be able to do that.
It's part of, of even the question I was asking like can we,
can we really be faithful to the text with that much
to take on?
Well, the reality is this is really one
long section in itself.
And so if we were to break it up, it wouldn't,
it wouldn't make sense in some ways.
It would kind of even dilute the theological principles
that God wants to teach us through this long section.
And we'll see some things about him.
Specifically, we're gonna see the theme
of God's holiness very clearly in this today.
God's holiness His, his set apartness and,
and how he is sovereignly unique
and how he deserves all the praise he deserves.
All the worship. That's, that's
what we're gonna see very clearly.
We're also gonna see some things about us as humans
'cause we're gonna watch Israel mistreat, God misunderstand,
God mistreat him,
and then we'll learn how similar we are
in our lives even today.
So let's pray and ask for his help. God, we need you today.
We need you not just 'cause it's four chapters.
We need you all the time, anytime, every time
that we would see you rightly in your word,
that you've given us the encouragement of it,
but also the instruction and the correction of it.
So God, do that today in our hearts.
Help us to see it as you want us to see it
and see ourselves as you want us to see us all in light
of you and who you are.
Help us, God, holy Spirit speak in Jesus' name. Amen.
And so what we need to do first
before we get to those four chapters actually go back
before, uh, even the book itself, first Samuel, we,
we go back all the way to the context
and theme of why this was even happening at the time.
Because at the end of the book of Judges, which is right
before first Samuel, you'll find
that even though Israel was in the land
that God had promised them they were morally corrupt
and even theologically bankrupt like the end of Judges,
we looked at this a few years ago, end of judges is just a
horrific scene of
how far they had gone away from God.
They were morally corrupt, theologically bankrupt,
blatant sin everywhere.
They were fighting each other.
They weren't fighting the enemies
they were supposed to be fighting.
And the question was arising at the time over whether God
would actually destroy them
because of their covenant
unfaithfulness that was on the table.
There was a question about that.
Or would someone restore Israel
from their drift away from God?
Enter Samuel this miraculous gift from the Lord
who is given back to God by his faithful mother.
Hannah and Samuel we remember was called from
before birth to Judge Israel to be a priest for Israel,
to be a prophet for Israel.
This is Samuel's new role yet again,
the situation he was called from was not pretty.
You remember Samuel's life was early on in the tabernacle
around Eli, the faithful priest and his sons Hockney
and Phineas who were extremely wicked,
even publicly wicked, right?
Everybody knew it and God was
not okay with it.
So you can read things in the Bible
and you can kind of wonder was God just kind
of like, ah, it's not a big deal.
Well, well no actually God is offended when
people dishonor him.
Like this is not something we can forget about God.
He is offended when people dishonor him.
Again, we're kind of going back a little bit
before chapter four, but this is what they were doing
and God's response to this is one Samuel 2 29 and 30.
Just as a reminder, Why do you scorn?
This is God talking. Why do you scorn my sacrifices
and my offerings that I commanded for my dwelling?
Why do you honor your sons above me
by fattening yourselves on the choices parts
of every offering of my people, Israel,
therefore the Lord, the God of Israel declares,
I promise your house and the house, your father should go in
and out before me forever.
But now the Lord declares far be it from me.
For those who honor me, I will honor
and those who despise me shall be lightly esteemed.
So that's the problem, right?
And then verse 33 says it this way, the only one
of you whom I shall not cut off from my altar shall be
spared to weep his eyes out to grieve his heart.
And all the descendants of your house shall die by the sword
of men, right?
See, God is offended when people dishonor him.
He's not up there disinterested, kind
of twiddling his thumbs just like, well,
whatever you can do whatever you want.
No, this God of justice is offended when people dishonor
him because he's holy,
Because He's worthy of us giving all the praise
and all the glory and all the honor to him.
He's worthy of praise
and service, not dishonor and selfishness.
And we'll see how God responds as we move into chapter four.
And what we come into chapter four Facing is a,
a fast-paced narrative
that involves the arc of the covenant.
Now, you might have heard of it before, it's the thing
that Indiana Jones was chasing, right?
That's the thing we're looking for.
But it's also, in fact, if you've been
through our Good Friday experience, you've seen a replica
of the arc of the covenant, as you can see right here.
This was a box
specifically designed by God.
It was covered with gold.
It was a symbol of God's presence with his people.
And it sat within the most holy place in the tabernacle
behind the curtain, in the eventual temple as well.
And it was where the high priest would go in and out
and he would meet the presence of God there at this
in a sense altar.
But that's the Ark of the Covenant.
And so we're gonna see this as a main piece
of this narrative going around the country.
Now, as Samuel remember, Samuel was growing in his stature.
He was growing in his prophetic figure in favor with Israel
as he was growing in that we saw some enemies show up
called the Philistines.
They were to be driven out of the land,
which is what kicks us into chapter four.
Just look at verse one.
It says that Israel went out
to battle against the Philistines.
So this is a shift in the narrative.
Now we've seen just kinda the backstory
of the characters and figure.
And then chapter four hits verse one, here's the battle.
What becomes quickly clear though is that what's about
to happen was a result
of them not asking God what they should do.
In fact, not listening to this man of God,
God's chosen leader, they go out in this battle.
In fact, they were routed pretty significantly.
That's why we get to verse three.
And when the people came to the camp, the elders
of Israel said, why has the Lord defeated us today
before the Philistines let us bring the ark of the covenant
of the Lord here from Shiloh, that it may come among us
and save us from the power of our enemies.
So that was their idea.
Okay, let's go get the ark and bring it here.
Maybe that will help. And so they end up bringing the ark.
In fact, Eli, the priest stays back.
He's trembling in fear that they were doing this.
But hti and PHUs, his sons accompanied the ark to the camp.
Now verse five, as soon as the ark of the covenant
of the Lord came into the camp,
all Israel gave a mighty shout so
that the earth resounded right?
They were pumped up because they saw the ark come in.
It was like this superstitious idea
that maybe this will be the thing that helps us.
Verses six through eight,
when the Philistines heard the noise of the shouting,
they said, what is this great shouting in the camp
of the Hebrews mean when they learned the arc
of the Lord had come into the camp,
the Philistines were afraid for, they said,
A God has come into the camp
and they said, woe to us
for nothing like this has happened before.
Woe to us who can deliver us from the power
of these mighty gods.
These are the gods who struck the Egyptians with every sort
of plague in the wilderness, Right?
So, so even the Philistines knew God's reputation.
Somehow they had heard about what he had done to
the Egyptians in Exodus.
Remember the 10 plagues splitting the the sea open
Like they had heard about that.
And so they didn't know who God was,
didn't have a relationship with him,
but they had heard what he had done before.
So they were worried
and they knew at this point like, all right,
we're gonna have to fight as hard
as we've ever fought before.
This is something we, we've never seen this before.
We're gonna have to come after this harder than ever
and watch what happens next.
Verses 10 and 11.
And so the Philistines fought and Israel was defeated
and they fled every man to his home.
And there was a very great slaughter
for 30,000 soldiers of Israel fell.
And the arc of God was captured and the two sons of Eli Hni
and Phineas died.
So Israel's great plan didn't work. Let's bring the arc.
Maybe this will be the answer and it didn't work.
But more than that,
the prophecy back in chapters two
and three that God had given to Samuel
and given to Eli came true Hoffey.
And Phineas died by the sword.
Even Eli himself, he keep reading in chapter four,
Eli himself, when he heard of the tragic news of his sons
and the arc, he fell over and died.
It's what God had said was going to happen.
And so that's part of it. That's bad enough.
But worst of all, the arc of God
had fallen into enemy hands.
The symbol of God's presence with his people
was now in the hands of pagans of his enemies.
The glory had departed Israel.
But I don't want us to miss something
and we get lost in the story.
Don't miss what Israel had been trying to do here.
They were completely dishonoring God.
They were scorning his sacrifices.
They were blatantly sinning even in the tabernacle.
Yet at the same time, they were wanting God to honor them.
Like you see this right?
They trivialized God, they trivialized his worship,
but at the same time they thought they could manipulate him
into giving them power and victory and battle.
You can't do it right?
God cannot be manipulated into honoring us.
Like this is clear right here
that God cannot be manipulated into honoring us.
Now we sit here two, 3000 years later, right?
And we look back at this
and we say, man, of course, Like it's very clear for us
to see that from our seat here, 3000.
Like we can see it.
It's there like, oh boy guys,
how did you ever think that would work?
Don't we do the same thing all the time?
Like, Like don't you And I do the same things
like we make light of worship
and then we expect God to bless it
Or, Or
or I like at the times I don't pray
and then I expect God to pour his presence out on me.
Or the times that we make life decisions completely on our
own and then we expect God to bless them wholeheartedly.
The or you're
addicted to pornography and then you expect
and assume that God's gonna protect you somehow
because you go to church more often than most people do.
Or you spend and spend
and spend, yet you rarely give to anything.
But you just know God's gonna continue to give you more.
Like, we'll, we'll decorate our houses with crosses
and we'll put phrases like verses in our bios.
Yet we're shocked somehow whenever God doesn't protect
or when our life hurts because we're living for ourself over
and over and over in our lives.
God is holy
I He will not be mocked.
God is holy and he cannot be manipulated into honoring us.
Like if you've turned your back on him,
do not be surprised when he allows you
to struggle and suffer.
But there's another truth we need
to remember about God here.
It's that he will be honored with or without us.
We might not be all in. We might in fact be dishonoring him.
He will be honored with or without us.
God let Israel lose the battle.
But watch what God does. Starting in chapter five. Now
Look at verses one and two.
When the Philistines captured the arc of God,
they brought it from Ebenezer to Ashton.
Then the Philistines took the Ark of God
and brought it into the house of Dagon
and set it up beside Dagon.
Now, Dagon was the Philistines God that they had chosen
to follow.
And bringing the ark into the temple of God was
of their God was symbolic, right?
It was almost like, you know, when you see in sports
and all these things, there's taunting
involved a lot in sports.
Like there's this measure of of tough ness
that you're gonna overcome and I'm gonna taunt you
because I just defeated you.
That's what's happening here.
They brought the arc into the temple of their God
to taunt the God saying, we defeated you, we defeated you.
You are our enemies. You're done. We won.
Yet as the philosopher Lee Corso would say, not
so fast my friend.
Look at verses three and four and
and listen, don't miss God's subtle humor here.
When the people of Ashdod rose early the next day,
behold Dagon had fallen face downward on the ground
before the ark of the Lord.
So they took Dagon, put him back in his place, kinda like,
oh well maybe an earthquake or something.
We don't know. But verse four.
But when they rose early the next morning,
behold Dagon had fallen face downward on the ground
before the ark of the Lord and the head of Dagon.
And both his hands were lying, cut off on the threshold.
Only the trunk of Dagon was left to him.
Pretty clear what's happening here, right?
Like this is the picture we put up at the beginning
of this, the series, right?
Like this is the idea who kept knocking over the statue.
Was somebody slipping in the air? And no, it was God, right?
It was God who knocked it over.
It was God who cut off its head, cut off its hands.
What he was doing was showing his power over any other God.
Yet it wasn't just this statue and that whole process.
Look at, look at verses seven, uh, six and seven here.
The hand of the Lord was heavy against the people of Ashdod.
And he terrified
and afflicted them with tumors, both Ashdod and his territory.
When the men of Ashdod saw how things were, they said,
the Ark of the God of Israel must not remain with us.
For his hand is hard against us and against Dagon our God.
So not only the statue itself,
God also afflicted the people.
Now there's an interesting word play
throughout these chapters.
On the word translated both honor
and heavy or fat.
We've seen it a number of times throughout the whole book
already, and it intertwines both that word
that's pretty much the same word in Hebrew honor and heavy.
It intertwines with the hand of God.
You'll see this show up here in a number of ways.
'cause think about this, it it said God's hand was not
on the heavy priest named Eli, right?
He said he was fat, he was
heavy, he was getting fat off them.
Sacra, he was heavy. God's hand was not on Eli.
But here we just saw that God's hand
was heavy on the Philistines, even to the point
of cutting off what from that statue, the hands
of Dagon, all of that was to show
that the God of Israel was to be honored
heavy in their eyes.
So there's this back and forth of the hand of God doing this
and the hand of God not doing this and cutting off hands
and heaviness and worship all of that.
That was to show that God is worthy
of the weight of glory.
Well, these Philistines are panicking at this point.
And so what they do from Ashton, they sent the ark up
to the next city called Gath.
We'll see Gath show up a little bit later in the narrative
in one Samuel, but, but what we see in Gath,
God's hand was heavy on them too.
And we see this, it's Tuma show up there just as much
as it did in Ash dot, right?
And so the gas, they're freaking out
and they see the same thing happen.
So they're like, we gotta get this thing outta here.
So they go up to Akron
and they take what happens in Akron, same thing.
Philistine city catches the tumor again
and all of this is happening over.
And so they were just like, we're done with this.
And they send it off back to Israel.
They had seen now that God is the Lord
and there's nothing they can do about it.
There's nothing they can prevent it.
So they just asked his heavy hand to leave them,
but they didn't send the ark away empty.
In fact, they actually made a a few golden mice
and golden tumors to accompany the ark
as it went back to Israel.
Now, just imagine you're on the receiving end of that.
Like what in the world tumors, mice? Like what?
What happened over there? Right? That's what you would get.
But that's the idea that they were trying to atone
in a way for their sin.
You get into chapter six, this is verses five and six.
The Philistines are debating this.
They say, so you must make images of your tumors, images
of your mice that ravage the land, give glory
to the God of Israel.
Perhaps he will lighten his hand from off you
and your gods and your land.
Why should you harden your hearts?
As the Egyptians and Pharaoh hardened their hearts
after he dealt severely with them,
did they not send the people away And they
departed, right?
They learned that when God's hand is heavy, you need
to honor him and you need to get outta the way
and say, okay, here you can have them back.
So check this out. I read this in a commentary.
This was interesting, the narrative here, it reads like
a military campaign conducted not by a human army
with a human commander, but by God himself.
Check this out. See, he, he traveled.
God traveled alone into Felicia
invading and conquering city
after city, executing their king Dagon,
getting the enemy to surrender
and then returning home triumphantly with the spoils of war.
Humans had nothing to do with it, it was just God himself.
But again, that's the point.
Remember, God will be honored with
or without us in the midst
of human weakness and failure.
We see God's power and we see the weight of God's glory.
Even his own people.
Yes, the Philistines understood it for the first time,
but even his own people understood this more as a result
where even at the end of chapter six, in verse 20, they say,
who is able to stand before the Lord?
This holy God, these same people
who had been turning their back on God for
so long, finally see it.
And they're like, who can stand? Who? What is this God?
And who can ever stand before him in his holiness?
That's the question, isn't it?
Like, do we ever consider that?
Do we ever really dig deep into the seriousness
of our sin, that it's rebellion
against the king of the universe?
Like, Do I let my heart open
to the reality of the weight of God's glory?
Like there's no way I could stay the same, right?
There's no way you could stay the same if you allow yourself
to really reflect on the weight of glory in God Almighty,
which is exactly what happens next.
Chapter seven of one, Samuel.
See, Israel finally understood
that it was their bankrupt theological perspective
that got them in this mess.
Like the reason they were having the trouble,
the reason they were defeated was
because of their perspective on who God wi is.
And Samuel, their judge, their prophet, their priest,
he was gonna lead them out of it.
So look at first Samuel chapter seven. Look at verse three.
And Samuel said to all the house of Israel,
if you are returning to the Lord with all your heart,
then put away the foreign gods and the ot.
Those were figures of Gods that from among you
and direct your heart to the Lord and serve Him only,
and he will deliver you outta the hand of the Philistines.
What'd he say? He said, repent.
I mean, that's what he, he said, turn back to God.
Get rid of everything else you've been trusting in.
Serve Him Verses five and six.
Then Samuel said, gather all Israel at mspa.
I will pray to the Lord for you.
So they gathered at Misbah, drew water, poured it out
before the Lord and fasted on that day.
And they said, there we have sinned against the Lord.
And Samuel judged the people of Israel at Misbah.
You see what they said, right?
We have sinned against the Lord.
Is that not a proper way to honor him,
to acknowledge that he's right, you are wrong.
That you've turned away from him, that you've been,
you've been trusting in yourself.
No, he's actually worthy of your obedience.
Is that not proper obedience
and proper worship, proper honor to just repent?
But here's the thing about this scene.
The threat hadn't gone away yet. Right?
Here's, look at verse seven.
When the Philistines heard that the people
of Israel had gathered at Mfah, the lords
of the Philistines went up against Israel, meaning they,
they began to attack.
And when the people of Israel heard of it, they were afraid
of the Philistines.
So, so here's the tension, right?
We see that the question again comes back,
had God abandoned Israel,
were things gonna go the same way like they did before?
Remember, they were all gathered together.
They thought they had this thing right?
They brought the ark with them
and they were like, okay, God, we're gonna win now.
And so here it comes again to fill his teeth.
Come have they have they come back to God?
Is he, is he truly with them? Have has he abandoned them?
Watch this. Verse eight.
And the people of Israel said to Samuel, do not cease
to cry out to the Lord our God for us,
that he may save us from the hand of the Philistines.
Notice their immediate response is different already.
They face the Philistines the first time. What they do?
Well, let's fix this problem.
Let's go get the ark and bring it back.
This time what they do, they cried out to God
verses nine through 11.
So Samuel took a nursing lamb
and offered it worshiped as a burnt offering to the Lord.
And Samuel cried out to the Lord for Israel.
And the Lord answered him
as Samuel was offering the burnt offering,
the Philistines drew near to attack Israel.
But the Lord thundered with a mighty sound
that day against the Philistines
and threw them into confusion.
And they were defeated before Israel.
The minute of Israel went out from as
but pursued the Philistines struck them as far as
below Beth Carr.
So check this out. Who actually defeated the Philistines?
God did. Now there was some responsibility they had to take.
Yes, kind of thing, but, but it was, God did.
Remember who did it in verse in chapters five
and six on his own.
God did it. God doesn't need us.
He defeated the Philistines on his own.
And just like he had predicted back with Hannah,
remember her prayer back in chapter two, verse 10,
the adversaries of the Lord shall be broken into
pieces against them.
He will thunder in heaven.
It's exactly what just happened, right?
God won the battle
and check out the result for Samuel seven verses 12 and 13.
Then Samuel took a stone and set it up between MPA and Shin
and called its name Ebenezer for he said, till now,
the Lord has helped us.
So the Philistines were subdued,
did not again enter the territory of Israel.
And the hand of the Lord was against the Philistines.
All the days of Samuel.
It wasn't perfect peace yet,
but the Lord had helped them.
He responded to their cry for help.
Which by the way, that's what that word ebenezer means.
It has nothing to do with Scrooge.
Don't think that way, right? Like it's, it's Ebenezer.
The word in Hebrew means stone of help.
It was the stone that Samuel set up as a marker
of remembrance that, hey, God has helped us.
Don't you remember? Like this is proof.
This stone reminds us. God helped us here.
God helped us here. God helped us here.
That's why when we sing that song here, I raise my Ebenezer.
We're not saying anything differently
than they're saying right here.
We're reminding ourselves that God is our help.
God is the one who comes near to us.
God is the one who answers our cry. He's our help.
He's our fortress. So why should I fear anything else?
The weight of God's glory is always heavier than anything
else, man.
I know life feels heavy at times, doesn't it?
The weight of God's glory is way
Heavier.
But here's, here's something else.
This section is meant to remind us of
something really important.
The flip side of even this in a way
that we are blessed when we honor God.
You remember he actually said that in chapter two, to those
who honor me, I will honor,
we are blessed when we honor God.
'cause you remember the people, the priests,
when they were living in wicked dishonor,
they were judged severely.
Their life was messy, their life was difficult.
Things were really hard in life.
Whenever they were dishonoring.
God, when the people tried to manipulate God
to treat his worship with corruption, yet still expect him
to bless them, what happened?
They were defeated. Even when the enemy,
the Philistines tried to mock God by putting the arc
of the covenant in the temple of Dagon, what happened?
Plagues. His hands were cut off.
When we dishonor, God, life hurts.
It doesn't work right? It's painful. We are defeated.
But when notice, remember when the people turned back
to God in chapter seven, when they directed their hearts
to the Lord, when they served him only what happened?
God won the battle for them.
Now, I'm not saying that when you turn to the Lord,
Everything's gonna work out perfectly.
Like you're gonna win the game.
You're gonna get the A, you're gonna make the
cut, you're gonna get the job.
Like that's not what we're saying here,
because Israel will see very quickly in the next chapter,
still had a lot of troubles,
even though they'd turned their hearts to God.
But we know that God will not bless those
who dishonor him.
Those who try to manipulate him, those
who stand in opposition to him, he will not bless those.
In reality, that's all of us.
All humans from birth are enemies of God
because of our sin.
And it's only like we think of how many good things we have,
how many good things unbelievers have.
It's only God's common grace that allows any of that
to come into life.
Yet, because he is so good and
because he loves so much, he
provided a way for even us as his enemies
to be saved from his wrath, to receive his blessing.
And that is through the life, death,
and resurrection of Jesus in our place.
Whereas we direct our hearts to him as we serve him,
he pours out his eternal blessings on us.
Blessings like having peace with him forever,
and peace with each other
where our eternity is secure
so we can face death without any fear,
where we know that we have a hope
and a joy in life today, no matter what we face,
those are his eternal blessings to his people.
And so just think about that today,
since he is the source of every blessing,
how can your heart be more tuned to his today?
Like how? How can you remove idols in your life so
that you can return to him?
That's the question. Today we see the
stark contrast.
What does God want from your heart today?